نعم يا شباب مجيد رضا ااا راح انابرد في
مدينه مشهد هو ثاني شخص يحكم عليه بالاي
ينفذ حكم الاعدام بحقه على صله بالاحداث
الجاريه في ايران اعتقوا لقد حوالي شهرين
من الان وجهت له التهابات قتل شخصين من
عناصر القوى الامنيه واصابه اربعه اخرين
في مدينه مشهد بجروح باستخدام السكين طبعا
طبعا تنفيذ الحكم همم كان في العام بحضور
همم ضعيف من الايرانيين الرسائل التي اراد
النظام الايراني من خلال هذا الحكم
توجيهها كانت واضحه البعض منها رسائل
خارجيه رسائل الى الخارجيه ان الطهاره
التي
تصريحات والمواقف والاذنات وحتى العقوبات
التي فرضتها عليها همم بعض الدول الغربيه
في مقدمتها الدول الاوروبيه وهي ماضيه في
تطبيق سياستها الداخليه دون ان تاخذ بعين
الاعتبار هذه التصريحات والمواقف الغربيه
الرسائل الى الداخل الايرانيه ايضا كانت
واضحه
همم الشمس وهي ان همم ايران او السلطات
الايرانيه كما وعد الرئيس ابراهيم الرئيسي
مضيئه بالتعامل بحزم مع كل شخص واجه القوى
الامنيه دون ان تاخذ بعين الاعتبار
الاذنات الخارجيه او حتى الانتقادات
الداخليه الرساله الثانيه هي ان اا طهران
ربما ارادت ان تنهي الجدل المتعلق بحكم
الاعدام الاول الذي نفذته قبل اربعه ايام
بحق الشاب محسن شكاري على ان ذلك الحكم
اثاره وما زال وما زال يثير الكثير من
الجدل في الداخل الايرانيه على اعتبار ان
محسن شكاري والاتهامات التي وجهت له هي
طبعا احد عناصر القوى الامنيه في احد
الشوارع في العاصمه الايرانيه طبعا لكن
عمليه الطعام تلك لم تؤدي الى مقتل همم
عنصر القوى وبالتالي كان هناك همم الكثير
من الجدل في الايام القليله الماضيه حول
الحكم بالاعدام على محسن شكاري تحديدا حتى
بموجب القانون الايراني بالتالي ربما على
السلطات الايرانيه من خلال السرعه بتنفيذ
الحكم ثاني بالاعدام هو انهاء هذا الجدل
الداخلي الذي عثر على خلفيه تنفيذ اول حكم
اعدام الرساله الثالثه والاخيره والتي
يمكن ان نستشفها من خلال تنفيذ حكم
الاعدام الثاني في الملا العام هو ان همم
السلطات الايونيه ارادت ان تقول لي
المتظاهرين ما قاله رئيس او قائد الحرس
الثوري قبل الشهرين من الان للمتظاهرين
وهو همم ان عودوا الى بيوتكم المظاهرات
انتهت عودوا الى بيوتكم لن نتتاهل اطلاقا
في التعامل مع كل من يشارك في هذه
المظاهرات التي اصبح بطانه ربما الاستهداف
على الامن والاستقرار في الداخل